the first concussion we measured with this device.
One of the things that I should point out is the device has this gyroscope in it,
and that allows you to measure the rotation of the head.
Most experts think that that's the critical factor
that might start to tell us what is happening in concussion.
So please watch this video.
Announcer: Cougars bring extra people late, but Luck has time,
and Winslow is crushed.
I hope he's all right.
(Audience roars)
Top of your screen,
you'll see him come on just this little post route,
get separation, safety.
Here it comes at you in real speed. You'll hear this.
The hit delivered by --
David Camarillo: Sorry, three times is probably a little excessive there.
But you get the idea.
So when you look at just the film here,
pretty much the only thing you can see is he got hit really hard and he was hurt.
But when we extract the data
out of the mouthguard that he was wearing,
we can see much more detail, much richer information.
And one of the things that we noticed here
is that he was struck in the lower left side of his face mask.
And so that did something first that was a little counterintuitive.
His head did not move to the right.
In fact, it rotated first to the left.
Then as the neck began to compress,
the force of the blow caused it to whip back to the right.
So this left-right motion was sort of a whiplash-type phenomenon,
and we think that is probably what led to the brain injury.
Now, this device is only limited in such that it can measure the skull motion,
but what we really want to know is what's happening inside of the brain.
So we collaborate with Svein Kleiven's group in Sweden.
They've developed a finite element model of the brain.
And so this is a simulation
using the data from our mouthguard from the injury I just showed you,
and what you see is the brain --
this is a cross-section right in the front
of the brain twisting and contorting as I mentioned.
So you can see this doesn't look a lot like the CDC video.
Now, the colors that you're looking at
are how much the brain tissue is being stretched.
And so the red is 50 percent.
That means the brain has been stretched to 50 percent of its original length,
the tissue in that particular area.
And the main thing I want to draw your attention to is this red spot.
So the red spot is very close to the center of the brain,
and relatively speaking,
you don't see a lot of colors like that on the exterior surface
as the CDC video showed.
Now, to explain a little more detail
about how we think concussion might be happening,
one thing I should mention
is that we and others have observed that a concussion is more likely
when you're struck and your head rotates in this direction.
This is more common in sports like football,
but this seems to be more dangerous. So what might be happening there?
Well, one thing that you'll notice in the human brain
that is different than other animals
is we have these two very large lobes.
We have the right brain and the left brain.
And the key thing to notice in this figure here
is that right down the center of the right brain and the left brain
there's a large fissure that goes deep into the brain.
And in that fissure, what you can't see in this image,
you'll have to trust me,
there is a fibrous sheet of tissue.
It's called the falx,
and it runs from the front of your head all the way to the back of your head,
and it's quite stiff.
And so what that allows for is when you're struck
and your head rotates in this left-right direction,
forces can rapidly transmit right down to the center of your brain.
Now, what's there at the bottom of this fissure?
It's the wiring of your brain,
and in fact this red bundle here at the bottom of that fissure
is the single largest fiber bundle
that is the wiring that connects the right and left sides of your brain.
It's called the corpus callosum.
And we think that this might be
one of the most common mechanisms of concussion,
and as the forces move down, they strike the corpus callosum,
it causes a dissociation between your right and your left brain
and could explain some of the symptoms of concussion.
This finding is also consistent of what we've seen
in this brain disease that I mentioned, chronic traumatic encephalopathy.
So this is an image of a middle-aged ex-professional football player,
and the thing that I want to point out is if you look at the corpus callosum,
and I'll page back here so you can see the size of a normal corpus callosum
and the size of the person here who has chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
it is greatly atrophied.
And the same goes for all of the space in the ventricles.
These ventricles are much larger.
And so all of this tissue near the center of the brain
has died off over time.
So what we're learning is indeed consistent.
Now, there is some good news here,
and I hope to give you a sense of hope by the end of this talk.
One of the things that we've noticed,
specifically about this mechanism of injury,
is although there's a rapid transmission of the forces down this fissure,
it still takes a defined amount of time.
And what we think is that if we can slow the head down just enough
so that the brain does not lag behind the skull
but instead it moves in synchrony with the skull,
then we might be able to prevent this mechanism of concussion.
So how can we slow the head down?
(Laughter)
A gigantic helmet.
So with more space, you have more time,
and this is a bit of a joke, but some of you may have seen this.
This is bubble soccer, and it's a real sport.
In fact, I saw some young adults
playing this sport down the street from my house the other day,
and as far as I know there have been no reported concussions.
(Laughter)
But in all seriousness, this principle does work,
but this has gone too far.
This isn't something that's practical for bike riding or playing football.
And so we are collaborating with a company in Sweden called Hövding.
Some of you may have seen their work,
and they're using the same principle of air to give you some extra space
to prevent concussion.
Kids, don't try this at home please.
This stuntman does not have a helmet.
He instead has a neck collar,
and this neck collar has sensors in it,
the same type of sensors that are in our mouthguard,
and it detects when he's likely to have a fall,
and there's an airbag that explodes and triggers,
the same way that an airbag works in your car, essentially.
And in the experiments we've done in my lab with their device,
we found that it can greatly reduce the risk of concussion in some scenarios
compared to a normal bicycle helmet.
So it's a pretty exciting development.
But in order for us to actually realize the benefits of technology
that can prevent concussion,
it needs to meet regulations.
That's a reality.
And this device is for sale in Europe
but is not for sale in the US, and probably won't be any time soon.
So I wanted to tell you why.
There are some good reasons and then there are some not so good reasons.
Bike helmets are federally regulated.
The Consumer Product Safety Commission has been given jurisdiction
to approve any bike helmet for sale,
and this is the test they use.
This is back to what I was telling you at the beginning about skull fracture.
That's what this test is for.
And that's an important thing to do.
It can save your life, but it's not sufficient, I would say.
So for example, one thing this test doesn't evaluate
is it doesn't tell you is that airbag going to trigger
at the right time and place, and not trigger when it doesn't need to?
Similarly, it's not going to tell you
is this helmet likely to prevent concussion or not?
And if you look at football helmets, which aren't regulated,
they still have a very similar test.
They're not regulated by the government, anyway.
They have an industry body, which is the way most industries work.
But this industry body, I can tell you, has been quite resistant
to updating their standards.
So in my lab, we are working on not only the mechanism of concussion,
but we want to understand how can we have better test standards?
And we hope that the government can use this type of information
to encourage innovation
by letting consumers know
how protected are you with a given helmet.
And I want to bring this back finally to the original question I asked,
which is, would I feel comfortable letting my child play football
or ride a bicycle?
And this might be just a result of my own traumatic experience.
I'm much more nervous about my daughter, Rose, riding a bicycle.
So she's a year and a half old,
and she's already, well, wants to anyway, race down the streets of San Francisco.
This is the bottom of one of these streets.
And so my personal goal is to -- and I believe this is possible --
is to further develop these technologies,
and in fact, we're working on something in my lab in particular
that really makes optimal use of the given space of a helmet.
And I am confident that we will be able to,
before she's ready to ride a two-wheeler,
have something available
that can in fact really reduce the risk of concussion
and comply with regulatory bodies.
And so what I'd like to do --
and I know that this is for some of you of more immediate nature,
I've got a couple years here --
is to be able to tell parents and grandparents when I'm asked,
it is safe and healthy for your children to engage in these activities.
And I'm very fortunate to have a wonderful team at Stanford
that's working hard on this.
So I hope to come back in a few years with the final story,
but for now I will tell you,
please don't just be afraid when you hear the word concussion.
There is hope.
Thank you.
(Applause)